live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
where dead is dumb cash is king and the
paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice let me give you a rule of life if
you want to be something you're not find
someone who is that find out how they
did it and what they do and who they are
as people and become that if you want to
be a great father find someone whose
children say I had a great dad
my dad is the best dad anywhere and they
really mean it and then go talk to that
guy how do you raise kids that are like
that you won't have a great marriage
talk to people who have a great marriage
not by the way great marriages I have
struggles but they have great marriages
anyway go talk to people that have an
incredible marriage and ask them how
they did it what do they do you want to
be skinny talk to skinny people how do
you do that how many chocolate chip
cookies do you eat you know you want to
be wealthy find wealthy people and ask
them how'd you do that see there's all
this liberal crap going around these
liberal politicians right now that says
that America is not fair and that we
should take money from people who have
earned it and redistribute wealth
because it's not fair there's structural
problems with the economy you just can't
get ahead in America the American green
dream is dead one actual [ __ ] wrote in
the LA Times this would be an LA Times
guy not a politician and said that the
millionaire next door is dead and he was
so tacky he did that the week after the
author of the book The Millionaire Next
Door was killed in a car wreck that's
how moronic that guy is and tacky to say
the least
I understand that was a friend of mine
so I resent that I'm still angry about
it
but the million our next-door is not
dead I've been doing this for 25 years
and I have run into millionaires and I'm
asked them how they did it and they tell
me the same kinds of things so a few
months ago we did our first ever
millionaire hour and it's becoming
quickly a tradition on the Dave Ramsey
show so if you are a millionaire and let
me help you with this a millionaire is
not someone who makes a million dollars
I'm watching some idiot politician you
know if you're a millionaire if you make
a million dollars well you're an idiot
you don't even know what a millionaire
is the definition of a millionaire is
someone is a million dollar net worth
your net worth is determined by
subtracting what you owe from what you
own your assets minus your liabilities
equals your net worth if you have a net
worth of a million dollars if you have a
million dollars in the bank and don't
have any debt you have a net worth of
million dollars that makes you a
millionaire it's not your income
it's your net worth now if you have a
million dollars and you had that
invested at 10% that's $100,000 your
income off your investments alone so
think about that so that that's why you
know I want to be a millionaire someday
I want to be a millionaire someday what
that means when people say that is they
want to achieve a net worth of a million
dollars because that will give them some
financial security it will give them the
ability to be generous more than they
are now it will be give them the ability
to live life with a little bit of margin
so we asked a few weeks ago for people
to call in an email and if they're a
millionaire and I'm asking you right now
if you're a millionaire call talk to
Kelly we want to hear your story because
we're gonna study for the next hour real
millionaires by the way let me help you
with this 88% that's 9 out of 10 of
America's millionaires our first
generation rich they started with
nothing and became millionaires and they
come from every race creed color
nationality sex everything men women
black white purple Latino whatever
they're all over the place they defy
logic and trying to define them
demographically there's something inside
of them called grit that caused them to
be able to save to scraped claw to win
they had hope and they believed and so I
can't stand it when people take away
people's hope in the political spectrum
say well you can't win without me I'll
help you all go to Washington and
anybody that believes that's just stupid
they're not gonna help you you gotta
help you so a million are hours before
you folks
Kenny is in Raleigh North Carolina hi
Kinney welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave guy be here thank you for
joining us so you have a net worth of
over a million dollars what's your net
worth sir I guess it's probably around
20 million pretty cool that's sweet yeah
and how in the world did you do that
well I was very lucky and inherited
everything Dave no that's not exactly
North Carolina and you know I just got
paid on it is what it was no it was it
was a lot of things but there was really
just one key moment probably as much as
anything I started my company to
restaurant chain I started at 24 years
ago which restaurants are knowledge what
restaurant train is it it's called
highway 55 yeah that's awesome man Jerry
worth 20 million how many stores will be
all got there's 115 now we're in eight
states soon to be ten and to foreign
countries just opened up in Denmark so
and you started with nothing started
with literally nothing I'd fired from a
job five hundred dollars in my pocket an
eighteen month old son at home and he
just purchased our first home so we were
land barons for the first time too and
here I was unemployed
we like to call it anyway you know we're
pretty poor so how many years before you
got to five stores well I actually got
the five in year two
yeah I'll tell you how I did it it was a
lot of in-house financing finding
clothes restaurants remodeling them with
my own scrub and equipment and getting
on my knees and doing a little
construction and remodeling closed
stores it's kind of how I got going
don't you going to auction sales and so
most of your net worth is in the
restaurant train I assume yes also
franchisor
I'm afraid so I was aware of franchisees
out there okay but you didn't inherit
anything know your average income
through those years must have been
pretty spectacular not in the early
years you know in the early years one
time as a matter of fact
first year I was in business I remember
I remember adding me adding it up I
worked open to closed every day 10:00 in
the morning till 10:00 at night and cook
the food and everything and I think I
made it we figured it out one time it's
about 260 an hour 2 dollars and 60 cents
an hour the first year I was in business
but here was the scary part you just
talked to me back then and you say hey
how's business you got a 45 minute
dissertation because I was passionate
about my two dollars or 60 cent an hour
job and and what we were trying to
accomplish
yep you already could see the future you
know I could see 20 believe it or not in
the very early days I could see 20 even
at the end of year one when I was
$35,000 behind on my food bells I could
still see 20 I really good and I didn't
quite know how I was going to get there
I didn't physically know if I'd be able
to make it because I was doing
everything back then but I could
definitely see 20 did you graduate and
you graduate from college yes right
thank goodness for athletics because I
graduated high school I was a middle of
the road as a matter of fact North
Carolina State recruited me and couldn't
get I couldn't get in I didn't have the
grades to get in so thank goodness I was
a pretty good baseball player and I was
able to go to Mount Olive North Carolina
and play at the junior college for the
first two years so was I sure what was
your GPA in college now I did wake up in
college I grew up a little bit and I
ended up with about a two five
cumulative GPA point / 10 million yeah
I want to ask you a couple more
questions can you hang with me through
the break absolutely all right
Wow the owner of highway 55 restaurants
20 million dollar net worth our first
call in on our millionaire theme our
kinney's with us we don't get a little
bit more info when we come back from the
break
it's a millionaire
theme our we're talking with Kenny in
Raleigh North Carolina one of our
millionaire callers to learn about how
to become a millionaire he started a
restaurant some 20-30 years ago called
highway 55 now he's got stores all over
America net worth of 20 million and had
an average GPA in college of 2.5 that's
another piece wisdom didn't didn't
inherit anything started out broke doing
it that way is that a fair summary what
you told me so far Kenny it doesn't
sound very impressive but that's pretty
fair yeah it's a lot of hard work in
between those years how many years ago
did you start yes 24 years ago and what
would you say your average personal
income is over all those years over all
those years probably 200,000 okay yeah
I've always purposely kept that down as
a matter of fact a few years ago when
the economy got tough I remember my CFO
walked innocent look everybody in here
needs to take a 10% pay cut and I said I
can't do that and I took a 50 I'm not
telling you that so you clapped me on
the back I'm just telling you that
sometimes you hear people out there they
act like CEOs and we're all just you
know beasts and we we take and run our
people around and for them crumbs and
it's just not the case so but yeah I
probably hold our you know I'm 52 okay
and how many new cars have you bought in
your life actually I just I just got
just got one and it's paid for you'll be
happy to know and the listeners but
that's my that's my thing you know it's
not close it's not it's not anything
fancy jewelry anything like that it's an
automobile when I was growing up in a
lower-middle-class is what we like to
call this family you know seeing a cool
car it was kind of my thing you know and
and actually I just got one I traded a
Tesla Model S for a Maserati and
and basically did a straight-up raid and
they're paid for cars so how many new
cars have you bought in your life your
car got probably probably pan okay let's
go well you can afford it you can afford
it okay talk to me about giving what
role has that play it played no I huge
it's what the whole company's founded
upon and if you got a second of I'll
kind of explain that it was 1991 I
started the company 92 I was 35,000
behind on my food bills and I was riding
home one night and I just remember
having this internal conversation and
just run it through my head you know you
often hear people say just be passionate
work hard you'll be successful well I
couldn't have been any more passion I
couldn't have worked any harder and here
I was 35,000 behind on my food bills so
I'm having this conversation and I wish
I could tell you this guy opened up for
something formatic like that happened
and it wasn't that way but just as clear
as I'm talking to you right now a voice
in my head said it's not about you it's
not about you and so I mean I kept me up
about half the night and I got up the
next morning and I changed the direction
of the company I made it about serving
everybody else in the company and within
six months we were in the black and what
I mean by serving them is we have
literally made over 50 minimum wage
employees owners of their own
restaurants through the years where we
in-house finances they have literally
started out of the minimum wage work
into management and then into ownership
and matter of fact July 1 I'm selling
two more does two young men that that
are very deserving and you know so by
putting the way I thought and making it
about meeting with me their needs before
my own even got met that was the real
breaking point that was where the
company changed and and as we look for
franchisees now we're looking for people
with that same character and that's by
the way that's more fun than all the
other stuff we're talking it's awesome I
tell you the first time that I was ever
able to you know there's a lot of people
out there that'll dangle that carrot and
say hey come come get it you know and
and burn out well when I was able to
when I said hey when I say you can be an
owner and the first time I ever made
somebody you know I stood him up in
front of a the rest of the managers and
I said look this person's earned it
they've worked hard they've done this
and that was one of the proudest days of
my life that was you know that and my
children being born
we're about hand in hand it was really
and and and every time we do it is just
a special so but giving yes very big
honor we have a foundation a golf
tournament we raise money we teach our
16 and 17 year olds that it's not about
them you know they actually bake cookies
for our foundation we raise money about
3 months out of the year we raised over
a hundred thousand about 125 thousand
and we give it away to kids causes so
we're teaching them amazing lessons at
the same time more than just working in
a hamburger place for minimum wage very
cool Kenny thank you so much wow what an
incredible story thank you so much
thanks for joining us
hey next time your national swing by I'd
love to meet you in person absolutely
very cool